si vous avez déjà consulté un site web
est presque tout le monde le fait pour
tenter de faire votre propre diagnostic
lorsque surviennent certains symptômes
cette chronique santé et pour vous
michel bonsoir bonsoir c'est bien plus
de plus en plus de gens qui vont sur des
sites web tenter de comprendre ce dont
il souffre est ce que c'est une bonne ou
une mauvaise pratique mais ces lignes
des pour et des contres mais une chose
est certaine dès le départ il faut
choisir les bons sites il y en a des
bons et des mauvais les bons sont ceux
qui proviennent des universités ce qui
provient des associations médicales
reconnues et qui citent leurs sources
scientifiques et médicales il ne faut
surtout pas aller sur des blogs et sur
tous les blogs personnels ou là tout le
monde discute on n'a vraiment pas de
références on sait pas si c'est vrai
aussi c'est faux et même certains
offrent des traitements il ya des
charlatans qui offre des traitements il
faut se tenir loin de ça et de chercher
des bons c'est d'abord et avant tout et
est-ce qu'on a étudié l'impact que cela
peut avoir de s'auto diagnostiquer comme
ça absolument ces lignes a déjà eu
plusieurs études à ce sujet et est ce
que l'on constate c'est que environ une
personne sur cinq est inquiète lorsqu
elles consultent ces sites là mais deux
personnes sur cinq mêmes sont anxieuses
lorsqu'elle découvre leur maladie le
seul bon côté c'est qu'une personne sur
deux se dit souvent rassuré puisque elle
découvre qu'elle n'a pas une maladie
très grave problème si problème il ya
c'est sans doute que certains deviennent
un peu accro à tous ces sites n'ont
absoluement et on a même eu un mot on
inventer un moule ça s'appelle cyber
conduit cyberespace internet contre
hypocondrie maladie imaginaire donc il
faut faire attention parce que beaucoup
de gens qui deviennent accro à sa ont
souvent des problèmes psychologiques dès
le départ et quand on parle d'un
problème psychologique souvent on peut
s'auto diagnostiquer un problème de
santé mentale et c'est là que ça devient
très délicat par exemple oui alors
souvent dans les cas de dépression les
gens dorment mal ils sont un peu anxieux
ils peuvent surtout d'une scie qui soit
1 dépression majeure ou même surtout
diagnostiqué une dépression légère ou
saisonnière ou même il se trouve d'un
stick qu'ils ont presque rien finalement
un problème stress alors souvent pour
faire attention et quand on arrive à ce
point là je crois que les gens devraient
absolument aller consulter un médecin et
non pas se fier son auto diagnostic
s'appelle dangereux et on imagine cette
plus en plus de gens qu'ils font que ça
peut changer un peu la relation entre le
médecin et son patient carrés avec son
diagnostic oui c'est le beaucoup changé
la pratique céline ya des gens qui
arrivent avec leur tour diagnostic sous
le bras et bons souvent les médecins
trop que ça peut ouvrir la discussion et
ça peut être positif d'autres médecins
trou que les gens sont agressifs il
suffit beaucoup plus à leur auto
diagnostic qu'à celui du médecin alors
il faut faire attention
je crois que il faut consulter un
deuxième médecin si on croit que ce
premier médecin là ne fait pas la faire
finalement pas toujours facile par
contre trouver un médecin séjour non
et vous êtes allez vous à boston la
semaine dernière pour parle pour visiter
le centre de surveillance mondial de
l'épidémie d'ebola vous nous préparez un
reportage oui demain reportage assez
long qui vont vous montrer cette équipe
de 60 personnes qui suivent seconde par
seconde
l'épidémie d'ebola actuellement et il ya
beaucoup de défis c'est pas facile à
faire
merci beaucoup céline